hey everyone bandit here let me just
start this video off by saying there
have been a lot of really good lore
breakdown videos out there and being
produced right now that have been both a
blessing and a curse to me trying to
make these videos on the one hand i love
learning about the universe of eldon
ring since i'm obviously trying to
create videos explaining eldon ring
links to them in the description below
but on the other hand i was actually
going to talk about radan next you know
the badass but there's a really good
video out on him currently which is
great then i was going to do mikola and
then millennia and then godwin but there
are already some great lore breakdown
videos out on each of them currently so
if you guys are interested in hearing
about these characters please do check
these other videos out that i mentioned
i don't think i'll be covering them on
this channel because those videos have
already done such a gosh darn great job
keeping things pg in here and especially
check out the ones from arlen grimm that
guy has a great very professional way of
piecing everything together anyway my
search for a character that hasn't been
fully delved into yet on the youtubes at
least as of writing this script would be
your one your only fingermaiden melanoma
except she's only just playing the role
of the fingermaiden but more on that
later and of course i will be explaining
the character's full story in a way that
anyone can understand although melinda
is admittedly perhaps the most vague
character to understand in a game that's
already full of vague characters which
means that there are inevitably going to
be a couple theories present in this
video more so than the previous
breakdown videos actually forewarning
this is going to be roughly 65 to 70
theory but hey we're all fans here so
play nice if you don't agree okay i will
also be covering everything we know
about her factually in-game as well so
you may as well just sit tight and see
what i have to say oh also spoilers in
this video biggins you've been warned
let's start by talking about the
surprisingly little amount of actual
confirmed facts we have on melania
in-game once you start playing and after
you've been served your first dose of
humble pie by getting stabbed a bunch of
times by this friendly looking chap you
then see your character dead on the
ground in some sort of tomb and while
you're just lying there dreaming of
better times and easier games you
suddenly see feet animal feet torrent
the goat horse or gorse as i
affectionately call him sniffs at you
then you hear a voice melina's voice she
tells torrent that fortune is on your
side and that you or one of your kind
are sure to search for the elden ring
even if it does violate the golden order
which seems like a very odd thing to say
but then the screen goes black and you
wake up later with the duo being nowhere
to be found but why was she here in the
first place and what business does she
have with a dead hero that might violate
the golden order that just got their
butt handed to them by the human
centipede according to mel in his own
words she was born at the foot of the
erd tree where her mother gave melana
her purpose which she has since
forgotten to make matters more
intriguing she also mentions that her
mother gave her said purpose from inside
the earth tree long ago you know who's
inside the earth tree queen america the
eternal yeah weirdly enough also melania
is dead she says it herself she is quote
burned and bodiless which explains the
whole fading in and out of thin air
thing but this is what answers why
melania sought you out when she found
you in that tomb earlier see after
playing for a short while she appears at
a sight of grace and offers you and a
cold by asking to take her with you on
your way to the elden ring which just so
happens to be inside the er tree she
wants to go back to where she was born
and where she received her purpose from
her mother because she has forgotten
what her purpose is and she wants to go
there to ascertain it for herself she
then gives you the spectral steed
whistle with which to summon torrent the
gorse for yourself and then she fades
away a little bit later she will appear
once again by a sight of grace and offer
you passage to the round table hold
which is a location where tarnished
warriors can gather and bolster each
other and receive smithing help from a
master huge who is imprisoned there by
order of queen america throughout the
game melina will appear here and there
giving you dialogue from queen merica in
the past that she can hear for some
reason and eventually when you reach the
archery and lane deal she will thank you
for escorting her there and then leave
for like two seconds because right after
you kill morgat for good this time and
try to enter the archery the roots of
the urgery will be sealed off with the
symbol of ratigan's great rune
preventing entry from you or anyone else
when you rest out of grace after that
melinda pops up again and says that you
need to become elden lord and pass
through those runes and her purpose that
she is now confident in is to assist you
with getting past those thorns the way
to do this is by setting the urge tree
on fire with the flame of ruin found way
up high in the mountaintops of the
giants you eventually make your way
there and beat the alleged last living
fire giant then are able to come across
the flame of ruin and this is where
melania's story can split one way or
another what she wants to do at this
point is fulfill her purpose and be the
sacrifice the kindling which is required
for the flame of ruin to set the urgery
ablaze which will effectively kill
herself in the act and end her story
however the much more interesting
details come from the alternate route
where you follow the path of the lord of
chaos by serving the frenzied flame
which melano will tell you repeatedly to
stay away from on your quest before
kindling the flame of ruin if you choose
to go and meet the three fingers who
will singe your body with the scars of
frenzy melano will then notice what
you've done and will leave you but
before leaving she will promise you that
should you become the lord of chaos she
will hunt you down and kill you and if
you go on to become the lord of chaos
then sure enough after you're done
gloating about getting a sick new hairdo
melana pops up she walks into the middle
of the urge tree after you're gone and
finds tauren's whistle and we can even
hear the whistle in this section of the
cutscene which is quite sad and while
she holds torn's whistle it burns away
in her hand implying that the flame of
frenzy which is meant to destroy
differences between all life-forms and
combine everything by burning everything
similar to what happened in neon genesis
a van gillian has in fact started by
burning and killing poor little torrent
your faithful gore steed who chose to
serve you melon then delivers the most
chilling line in the entire game by
addressing you as the lord of frenzied
flame and saying i will seek you as far
as you may travel to deliver you what is
yours destined death and when the camera
pans up to her face we can see that the
one golden eye that she's looked out of
the entire game is now glossed over in
grey no longer shimmering gold and her
other eye which has been closed the
whole game opens up as well revealing
her true eye color to be a bluish purple
and that is the end of everything we
know about melania in the game like i
said she's extremely vague but here is
where we're going to pivot and switch
into theory mode for the remainder of
the video to piece together how she's
connected to america and why her eye is
weird and why being the lord of chaos
pisses her off so much you know besides
the whole betrayal and murder of torrent
that is because let's face it that
pisses me off too let's start with what
is perhaps the most intriguing and
obvious design choice with melina her
eyes they've got several things going on
there at the end of the game not only do
we see her closed eye opened but her
opened eye has faded from color
personally i think this means that the
grace which was keeping her spirit alive
and giving her eye that golden color has
faded away as a result of everything
burning in the frenzied flame and we now
see that another power maybe even her
own is granting her life by looking at
the color of her opened tattoo eye now
most people including myself when seeing
melon as i being closed with a tat over
it immediately thought of the other most
recognizable face in the entire game
ronnie the witch and how she also has a
closed eye with a similar tat over it on
the opposite side of her face although i
can't tell if it's the same marking or
not this is actually just one of several
strange similarities that the two girls
have in common the others being the fact
that they are both spirits that fade in
and out of thin air with the exact same
sound effects and blue particle magic
effect they both have ties too and are
the only characters that mention torrent
several times throughout the game even
remembering to thank the steed for his
service they both give you spectral
items they both speak with a very slow
and clear voice they both appear to be
around the same age visually they both
had their original bodies burned away
and the biggest one is that technically
ronnie's real face the spirit face
mirrored to her doll face that's
attached at the eye has the eye closed
correctly oriented and matches up
exactly with melano's facial structure i
don't think it's possible to not compare
the two and try to find some sort of
connection as far as lore is concerned
and indeed many people have been trying
to non-stop since the game was released
the problem is that there isn't an
obvious connection between them besides
their similarities i already mentioned
so i decided to look harder i pondered
what the shared tattoo could be for the
longest time like whether it was a
tattoo of the fingers or something like
that there are three protruding
finger-like shapes though so if it were
a tattoo of the fingers it would have to
be the three fingers but melinda hates
the three fingers and the frenzied flame
so that's unlikely i was at a loss until
i stumbled across somebody on the
internet and i'm so sorry but i forgot
who it was that mentioned it actually
looks like a crow foot and honestly that
makes perfect sense for several reasons
because not only are crow feet shaped
exactly the same way with the fourth
digit being behind the front three but
the talons can each also individually
bend down like the one shown on the
right side of melanis tattoo and get
this the term crowfeet is also used in
real life as a term to refer to the
wrinkles at the edge of your eyes wink
wink hint hint but what does a crow foot
have to do with anything in elden ring
well symbolically crows have always been
a representation of death just in
general i think it's a similar situation
in this case and because of that it
actually serves to connect melana to
another widely believed theory about her
origin and that would be that she is or
used to be none other than the
mysterious entity known as the
gloam-eyed queen or the dusk-eyed queen
depending on what item description
you're reading the glomide queen is
mentioned several times in various item
descriptions so it's clear that the
developers wanted us to think about who
she might have been or possibly even
still is and annoyingly we know that
they have no problem with using code
names for otherwise well-known
characters just to be confusing like
when they continually referred to
melania as the valkyrie in the shaded
castle for no reason so i think they're
definitely doing something similar with
the dusk eyed queen both gloam and dusk
are words that mean twilight which is
the section of the day that bridges the
sunlight and moonlight together and
melon melano's opened tattoo eye has a
blueish purple color which is literally
the color of a twilight sky additionally
the glomite queen was said to be the
leader of the godskin apostles who get
this worshiped and followed the rune of
death also known as destined death and
wouldn't you know it after melinda
remembers her purpose all of a sudden
she starts talking about how the world
needs a good dose of death
indiscriminate which means it would be
everyone's destiny to die and of course
at the end there is the infamous threat
of giving you your destined death which
is a very blatant call out i mean guys
these things are clearly meant to stick
out to us so that we can connect them
with other pieces of lore melana is
clearly connected in some inexplicable
way to destin death and adding her
gloamy eye to the mix it really feels
like she's got to be related to the
glomide queen somehow so let's switch
gears briefly and talk about who the
glomide queen is we know that she
existed long before the events of the
game and that she was actually an
emperian and was even chosen by her own
two fingers as a quick reminder an
imperian is an individual who has the
power or ability or permission to become
a vassal to an outer god becoming a god
themselves just like queen america we
also know that prior to malekith's
possession of the rune of death which is
something i explained more in the
america video it was the gloam-eyed
queen that was in possession of it it's
what gave her and her followers the
ability to wield the black flame which
comes from the glomide queen's sword
called the godslayer greatsword when the
black flame was superpowered by destin
death it had the power to kill gods
which was the godskin's ultimate goal
but why try to kill gods in the first
place and how did the glow might queen
manage to get her hands on the rune of
death in between its fusion with the
elden ring and its possession by
malaketh here's what i think this all
means since it specifically states that
the source of the black flame the
godskin apostle's power comes from the
sword of their leader the gloamide queen
and that they quote serve destined death
directly and that destined death is a
rune that was plucked from the golden
order aka america's elden ring and since
the defeat of the glomite queen by
malekith also meant the sealing away of
destin death into malakith and
conveniently the disappearance of the
gloamide queen i think that the rune of
death was literally the glowmide queen
just like i think the great rune
depicted on radigan's seal literally is
radigan himself throughout the game as
i've talked about in the other videos we
continually see imperial people that are
literal vessels of runes merica the
empirian was the elden ring ratigan was
also a great rune possibly the rune of
order ronnie was the great rune of the
unborn and now the glomide queen an
empyrean is the rune of death which when
it's separated from the golden order
became an actual living person that was
set on doing one thing delivering
everyone their destiny of death in order
for them to die and be reborn of the
urgery which is the way life was
originally designed to cycle she wanted
to deliver death indiscriminate which
should sound familiar starting with
queen merika the god who defied death
that's why destin death aka the dusk
guide queen channeled her god slaying
power through her sword creating the
omnipotent black flame that served as
the ultimate death for all beings and
creating her own cult of god skin
apostles to follow and aid her in the
war against merica the eternal in
response merica sent her shadow malekith
to fight against the glomide queen and
her army and when he defeated her he
absorbed her rune into himself removing
destin death from the world and
crippling the power of the black flame
while also corrupting his own mind
irreparably since this was all merrick
is doing and therefore her own will that
destined death should be removed and
kept removed in the first place and
placed in her half-brother malakath for
safe keeping i believe that is why it
says in-game that she betrayed her
brother malekith but now let's jump back
to melina like i mentioned before she
does seem connected to the dusk eyed
queen because of her glow my in her
death tattoo and her weird obsession
with bringing the world death that does
not discriminate but the biggest
question is how is she connected well
let's think back to where melania says
she came from she says she was born at
the foot of the earth tree this is what
the foot of a tree looks like it's right
where the roots begin actually kind of a
strange place to have a baby if you ask
me and i know that according to the
description of a golden rune 6 there is
a legend that being born at the foot of
the herd tree brings good fortune but
melana is a bit different because
remember how she says not only that she
was born there but that her mother gave
her her purpose from inside the tree and
remember how i said merica is the only
person we know of in that tree well
that's not actually completely true see
melania specifically says that her
mother is inside the tree and the only
reason marika ever entered the tree to
our knowledge was to shatter the elden
ring after which she was imprisoned by
the greater will and rendered unable to
move or birth children for that matter
and now that i'm talking about it it is
weird that melania talks a lot about
america but never confirms that america
specifically is her mother but there's
no other mother inside the urgery right
wrong there is someone else that could
fit the description of a mother and that
would be the rune of death the
gloam-eyed queen the description of the
godskin swaddling cloth states that the
gloam-eyed queen would swaddle newborn
apostles with the cloth and swaddling a
newborn means you were present for their
birth which means that they were most
likely her own children that she had
just given birth to explaining the
existence of the godskin apostles and
giving the dusk eyed queen the ability
to be called a mother and according to
the description of death root after
ronnie stole the rune of death and the
murders transpired on the night of the
black knives the rune of death spread
throughout the land giving rise to those
who live in death by way of the roots of
the great tree which again is another
word for the er tree not sure why they
use different words sometimes and melano
was born specifically at the foot of the
earth tree with her mother inside the
tree at its roots where destined death
the glomide queen was spreading i think
this means that melano is either the
daughter or the reincarnation of
destined death itself
[Music]
but there are still some remaining
questions that need to be answered like
what about mel in his body which she
says was burned and why is ronnie so
similar to her and why do they both know
torrent keep watching we're getting
there and we're almost done with this
wild ride remember that ronnie fessed up
to being the mastermind behind all of
the events that transpired on the night
of the black knives which means that she
must have also been the one who injected
the roots of the artery with the rune of
death since she was the one who stole it
and was last in possession of it that
means it was her plan for death route to
spread through the lands between but why
well like i explained in much more
detail in the ronnie video she plotted
to overthrow the entire golden order and
she's successful depending on one thing
and that one thing is you the player
tarnished see her plan doesn't go
anywhere after the night of black knives
if you don't sign up to help her out
because ronnie isn't stupid she knows
that she alone can't defeat the god
queen america or the elden beast
residing inside she needed someone more
powerful to do it for her a tarnished
warrior with a blessing of grace for
instance this is why she can only be
summoned after the final fight
immediately remarking that the battle is
over which proves that she was concerned
about it but also that you executed her
plan swimmingly but before any of that
could happen she also knew that the urge
tree itself was closed off barring
anyone from entry by the magical rune of
ratigan her father so as she did with
everything else she devised a plan to
get rid of the magical barrier and that
plan was to use destined death to
rebirth the gloam-eyed queen and have
her find and guide a tarnished warrior
with fortune on their side to the earth
tree and then burn it down to allow them
entry i think ronnie may have only used
half of her essence to inhabit the form
she's in today since it is pretty weird
that her spirit appears to be only half
connected to her doll body i mean
seriously what gives that's the only
explanation i can think of for this very
odd design choice the other half of her
essence may have been fused with the
rune of death in order to spread it
through the roots of the earth tree to
be reborn out of the tree thus creating
melanin explaining why she has a yellow
grace eye and why she looks exactly like
ronnie's spirit face and why her magic
looks the same etc etc and if this is
true then this means that torrent was
originally ronnie's pony and that she
may have even created him as a spectral
steed so that melania could use him to
find the tarnished warrior and after
melina and torin found you and gave you
tauren's calling whistle ronnie found
out about it and paid you a visit
personally however upon meeting you for
the first time she lies to you and says
that her name is actually rena but then
gives you a spirit calling bell from
supposedly tauren's former owner i think
she was actually torrance former and
original owner and that she lied to you
because she was testing you by
concealing her actual identity she
wanted to know for sure that you were
the one fate had chosen for her the one
with fortune on your side that's why she
waits for you alone in her tower and
makes sure that you want to help her out
even though she tells you she doesn't
recall giving you an invitation and says
that fate itself must have steered you
to her so to recap all this crazy
theorizing in a nutshell basically i'm
insinuating that long ago america
plucked the rune of death from the elden
ring which created the golden order the
rune of death became destined death also
known as the gloam-eyed queen bent on
returning death to the world and
creating the god-skin apostles america
sent malketh to kill destined death and
absorb it into his body later ronnie
learned of all this nonsense and decided
to steal the rune of death from malekith
and use it to slay her own physical body
then infuse it into the roots of the
earth tree with half of her spirit
essence destin death now fused with some
of ronnie's essence was reborn at the
base of the earth tree as melana with
the purpose of finding a tarnished with
fortune on their side and guiding them
to the archery sacrificing herself to
burn it down and allow them access this
is why melania gets so peeved at you for
choosing the path of the frenzied flame
because not only do you deny her of her
true purpose and kill torrent but you
also become an eternal being who she now
without grace and guided by her true
nature is destined to bring death too
and that my friends is a hell of a
theory complicated but understandable
and with lore like this i'm finding more
and more each day that nothing is ever
as simple as it seems at first in this
game and most things are connected in
some way to one another like i didn't
even go into death route creating those
who live in death which created the
ghost flame which created the death of
birds the mother of which is something
called the twin bird which is said to be
the envoy of another outer god but this
video is already packed enough and i'll
explain that in another video if you
guys want that being said though thank
you so much for watching and i hope you
enjoyed it please consider leaving a
like below as these videos take a lot of
time and effort to make and piece
together and it really helps out with
the algorithm and for the love of
america subscribe to stick around for
lots more let me know in the comments
below what you thought of this video and
what you'd like me to cover next and
that's all i've got for this one so as
always i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day this is bandit looking
forward to seeing you next time and
signing out
[Music]
you